welcome everyone to m coding with james
murphy that's me where we try to get
just a little better at programming
every episode so that we can take
unknown hours to automate our 30 second
interaction with the coffee machine
today we're talking about parallel
programming specifically how to unlock
and use all of your cpu cores in python
i'm also an independent consultant so if
you or your company needs python
consulting please check me out i'll
motivate this with the following extract
transform load workflow
we start off with a bunch of audio files
that we want to read in process and then
write back out
we use scipy to read in each audio file
as a numpy array we then operate on the
numpy array in this case adding random
normally distributed noise
and then we write back out our new
transformed audio file
obviously adding random noise to a bunch
of files isn't necessarily a very useful
thing to do
but please consider each of these steps
as just a stand-in for real workflow
extract data from some location whether
it be a file a database or whatever do
something useful to transform it in
memory then you take your transform data
and store it out somewhere else
let's see how this primitive etl
performs in a loop
here we have 24 audio files they're just
sine waves for like four minutes long
then let's process each of them and see
how long it takes
right off the bat it's taking about a
half second to process each file maybe
for a single file you might be okay with
waiting half a second
but if you're starting to process
hundreds or thousands of these files
this is going to add up really quickly
but let's take in the handy cpu monitor
and run that process again
as you can see although it's going to
take 12 seconds to finish we're only
utilizing 24 percent of our cpu
approximately
wouldn't it be great if we could utilize
all of our computing power to get the
job done faster
there are three big contenders for how
to deal with multiple tasks in python
there's async io threading and
multiprocessing
as the name suggests async io is
primarily concerned with i o bound
operations
async i o is built to allow tasks to
cooperatively pause themselves and allow
other tasks to run particularly while
they're doing nothing just waiting
so if the bulk of your program time is
spent reading or writing to disk or
waiting on a network connection then
async io might be a good choice
while we're definitely reading and
writing files assume for the sake of the
argument that the transformation step
the one we're actually doing raw
computation is where the bulk of the
time is spent
in that case we'd say we're compute
bound and async io wouldn't be a good
fit okay what about using threads
in a lot of languages besides python
using threads would be the answer here
the ultimate reason that we didn't see
100 cpu utilization was because python
is just running on a single thread on a
single cpu
that one cpu might have been close to
maxed out but the seven others were just
sitting idle
however just take a look and see what
happens when we swap things out for a
threading solution here's the cpu
monitor again
and let's run it okay here we go
things look like they're going well
but we're still only getting 32 31 cpu
utilization it was a little bit faster
almost eight seconds not 12 but we still
didn't get anywhere close to full cpu
utilization with seven extra cores we
should expect things to go six or seven
times faster and here's where we get to
the big elephant in the room with python
and threads
python well specifically c python which
is the python that 99 percent of you are
going to be using has what's called the
global interpreter lock a lock is a
parallel processing primitive that helps
threads prevent themselves from
accessing the same data at the same time
in particular to prevent one thread from
reading or writing some data while
another thread is writing to it only one
thread can acquire this lock at a time
which is insured by your operating
system and by your actual hardware if
two threads are trying to access the
same data at the same time one of them
will get the lock first and it's able to
do its thing then it releases the lock
and the other one can grab it well as
the name suggests the global interpreter
lock is a global lock around the entire
python interpreter
in order to advance the interpreter
state and run any python code a thread
must acquire the gill
so while it's possible to have multiple
python threads in the same process only
one of those threads can actually be
executing any python code while that's
happening all the other threads just
have to sit around and wait now we did
still get some speed up here and the
reason for that is simple you only need
to acquire the guild to run python code
your python code can then call out to c
code or other external code that doesn't
care about the interpreter
during this time it can drop the gill
let another python thread do its thing
and wait on that c code to finish
simultaneously in our case this is what
happens when we read and write files to
disk
at the os level it's possible to wait on
multiple files to read and write at the
same time and that's where the savings
is happening here however for our
transform operations we don't get so
lucky
threading in python can still be useful
mostly for i o bound things but it can
also be useful in say a gui application
where you want to run a long running
calculation off the main thread to
maintain responsiveness
however in python at least for the near
future we're not going to be able to use
threading to get maximum utilization out
of our cpu
therefore we turn to the third option
multiprocessing for our compute bound
tasks
in our case it's going to work
fantastically because all of our tasks
are completely independent of each other
processing one audio file has no impact
on processing any others
while you may eventually need to dive
down to the level of managing single
processes most of the time you don't
need the process object i'd say 90 of
the time what you really want is a pool
object a pool object represents a
process pool
you just tell it what tasks you want to
execute it takes care of creating the
processes scheduling the tasks and
collecting the results all in a thread
and process safe way you can control the
maximum number of processes that you
want it to start like this
but if you just leave it blank it'll
just use one per cpu
each process is its own python
interpreter
in particular they no longer have to
fight over the gill they all own their
own gill
we're using a with statement here to
ensure that all the processes coordinate
and terminate gracefully
there are three basic methods that the
pool offers map imap and imap unordered
imap unordered immediately returns an
iterator then asking for an actual
element of the iterator is wet blocks
imap unordered will return the results
to you in whatever order they finish in
so if some tasks complete quicker you'll
get those back faster
let's see how it goes
i don't know if you saw it but we did
have a full spike to 100 cpu utilization
and the total time was only three and a
half seconds
also notice that because we used the
unordered version our results did not
come back in their original order this
is actually part of the reason that i
return the input file name as part of
the result
if i'm getting things out of order i
need to know which task this
corresponded to
let's try again with the normal imap
once again we had a brief period where
we had maximum utilization and once
again it finished in about three and a
half seconds this time the results are
guaranteed in order
that means that we may have waited a
little bit for example 0 to finish even
though example 1 was already done it
just queued up for a bit
and then finally there's map
map just blocks and waits there until
all the results are ready returning them
in a list
once again it took about 3.5 seconds
total and the results are guaranteed in
order
now that's more like it just two lines
of code and i get to fully utilize all
of my cpus
then i can scale this operation to as
many tasks as i want just by having more
cores
and with access to relatively cheap core
hours from online compute services this
can be a surprisingly scalable way to
process a lot more data without waiting
a lot more time okay great we've seen
sort of the best case scenario using
pool.map here
next let's take a look at just a few of
the ways where everything can go wrong
let's just take a look at a few
different scenarios one running normally
on just a single cpu and the other
running multi-processing using the pool
stuff that we just talked about in the
normal case i'll just map the given
function do work over the given set of
items and then convert it to a list and
in the multi-processing case we'll use
pull.map
pitfall number one trying to use
multiprocessing in a situation where the
overhead of creating processes and
communicating between them is greater
than the cost of just doing the
computation suppose all we wanted was a
quick calculation like multiply by 10.
let's see how the multiprocessing and
normal cases compare
using multiprocessing it took 0.77
seconds
but just doing the computation outright
on a single cpu took less than 100th of
a second
creating processes and communicating
between them can be very expensive so
keep that in mind and only apply
multi-processing to things that are
already taking a long time pitfall
number two trying to send or receive
something across process boundaries
that's not picklable
threads share virtual memory so a
variable that you create in one thread
can be accessed in another thread
processes on the other hand have their
own address space and do not share
virtual memory
without specifically using something
like shared memory a process cannot
access variables from another process
the way multiprocessing gets around this
is by serializing everything using
pickle
it then uses an inter-process
communication method like a pipe to send
bytes from one process to another
the takeaway is that you can't send
anything that isn't picklable if you try
you'll get an error like this in this
case this lambda function this lambda x
x plus one is not a pickable object
of course the same thing goes for the
result objects you can't return anything
that's not pickleball
pitfall number three trying to send too
much data
remember all the items that you're using
need to be serialized and sent between
processes
if you have a lot of data like numpy
arrays then this can be a big slowdown
instead of passing the data from process
to process consider sending a message
like a string that informs the other
process how to create the data on its
own
for instance in our audio example we
didn't read the wave files here and then
send them over
instead we just passed the file name and
have the separate process load the file
itself pitfall number four using
multiprocessing when there's a lot of
shared computation between tasks
here's a basic fibonacci implementation
we want to compute the first ten
thousand fibonacci numbers
we go ahead and try our experiment and
what do you know
doing it on eight cores was actually
faster than doing it on one
but of course we've been tricked it is a
huge waste to be computing these ten
thousand fibonacci numbers independent
of each other since there's so much
overlap if we just changed our
implementation to reuse shared
computation then we could compute the
first ten thousand fibonacci numbers
instantly
and pitfall number five not optimizing
the chunk size
map imap and imap unordered all take a
chunk size parameter
instead of submitting each item as a
separate task for the pool items are
split into chunks
then when a worker grabs more work it
grabs an entire chunk of work
bigger chunks allow individual workers
to have to take less trips back to the
pool to get more work however there's
also a trade-off because a bigger chunk
means that you have to copy more items
at once across process boundaries
this could potentially cause you to run
out of memory if your chunk size is too
large
if you're running out of memory consider
setting a smaller chunk size and also
consider using imap or imap unordered
instead of map remember map keeps all of
the answers in memory in a list
whereas imap and imap unordered can give
you results as they come in rather than
storing all of the results all at once
so a larger chunk size tends to be
faster but use more memory and a smaller
chunk size uses less memory but is
slower
so if you really want to optimize the
performance as much as you reasonably
can in python then don't forget to
optimize that chunk size parameter as
well and that's all i've got for today
thank you so much for watching there
will definitely be more multi-processing
threading and async content coming
as always thank you to my patrons and
donors for supporting me
if you enjoyed this intro to
multiprocessing please consider becoming
a patron
and as always slap that like button an
odd number of times see you next time